اول شيء تفعله عندما تدخل من باب المطار
تنظر الى هذه الشاشات سواء كنت مغادرا او
قادما فيها المعلومات التي تحتاجها عن
رحلتك
وحقائب هذا ما فعله مسافر مطار رفيق
الحرير الدولي في بيروت تفقدوا شاشات
المعلومات للمغادره والوصول لكنها بدت
بيضاء وعليها رساله بالاحمر موجهه الى حسن
نصر الله الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني
يبدو انه تم اختراق نظام شاشات المعلومات
لعرض هذه الرساله وادى هذا الاختراق الى
تعطيل نظام فحص الامتعه في المطار لفتره
وجيزه المكتوب في هذه
الرساله باسم الرب والشعب مطار رفيق
الحريري طبعا هي رساله موجهه الى نصر الله
يقول مطار رفيق الحريري مش مطار حزب الله
وايران يا حسن نصر الله ما رح تلاقي نصير
اذا بليت لبنان في حرب تتحمل مسؤوليات
وتبعاتها يا حزب الله ما رح نحارب نيابه
عن حدا طيرت مرفانا والان بدكم تطيروا
مطارنا بسبب ادخال السلاح فليتحر المطار
من قبضه الدويله
ونجد هذا الشعار لجماعه تسمي نفسها جنود
الرب وحساب هنا غير معروف الاسم اسمه صاحب
الكلام جنود الرب هم مجموعه من الشباب
المسيحيين ظهرت لاول مره في محله كرم
الزيتون بمن منطقه الاشرفيه ببيروت تصف
الجماعه نفسها بالمدافع عن منطقتها ضد ما
تصفه بالافكار الشيطانيه والمخدرات
والسرقات اعدادهم بالمئات يرتدون الاسود
يحملون السيوف والصلبان وقد ظهروا عده
مرات لتامين المصارف في تلك المناطق
مجموعه جنود الرب نفت مسؤوليتها عن قرصنه
شاشات عرض المعلومات في مطار بيروت الدولي
استذ استمعوا
لهم نحن من هون بقول لكم بنمشي نفسين
قاطعا اي عمل بينعمل وبنحط عليه شعار
لجنود الرب الا على صفحاتنا الرسميه لما
بدنا نعمل شغله نحن على راس السطح بعملها
وبنحطها على صفحاتنا
الرسميه ما هو سبب هذا الاختراق لشاشات
مطار بيروت الدولي من الذي له مصلحه بمثل
هذا الاختراق كيف فسرت هذا من تقول ما حصل
بمطار بيروت الدولي مرفوض وغير مقبول اللي
قدر يسن شاشات نظام امن المطار قادر يخترق
انظمه انظمه اكبر يجب على القوى الامنيه
التحرك السريع لوقف المفتعل
ومحاسبتهم اشد عقاب لعدم تكرارها الياس
يقول بغض النظر عن من فعلها وان كنا سنصل
بالتحقيق الى الفاعل الحقيقي ام لا ما حصل
اليوم في مطار بيروت يؤكد المؤكد مره اخرى
لبنان بحاجه لمطار ثان مفيد مصطفى قال هذا
عمل موظف من الداخل ويبدو ان هذا الموظف
لديه معلومات دخول سلاح عبر المطار وهذا
اهم في الرساله اما فؤاد غزيري فيقول ما
حصل يؤكد مره اخرى على الوضع المزري الذي
يعانيه مطار بيروت الدولي وهشاشه الانظمه
والمطلوب ليس فقط الكشف عن الفاعل بل
محاسبه المسؤولين على كل حال هناك
احتمالان لهذا الاختراق الاول هو هجوم
سيبراني من قبل لاجهزه محترفه الشاشات
مرتبطه بجهاز كمبيوتر والكمبيوتر متصل
بالانترنت اذا كان عليه نظام ويندوز قديم
فمن السهل اختراقه بحسب خبراء الامن
السبراني الاحتمال الثاني هو ان يكون احد
موظفي امن المطار على ارتباط بجماعه معينه
مثلا طلبت منه نشر هذه الرساله انتم ما
رايكم اكتبوه في التعليقات